[Música]
hola bienvenidos a kobe 19 la semana en
américa el espacio de france 24 en el
que hacemos un recorrido por las
principales noticias las más destacadas
relacionadas con la pandemia del cob y
19 en nuestro continente en el
continente americano soy santiago lópez
gonzález y a continuación les presento
el sumario de temas que tenemos paraguay
la universidad de oxford y el
laboratorio astrazéneca sufrieron un
traspié al dar a conocer que uno de sus
voluntarios que participaba en uno de
los estudios para el desarrollo de una
vacuna contra el cob y 19 falleció
veremos en detalle este caso para
conocer las posibles causas de este
fallecimiento y qué implica para la
investigación en curso ante el rebrote o
la incapacidad de frenar el avance de la
pandemia del cob y 19 el teletrabajo
sigue siendo una estrategia para
mantener activa la economía sin exponer
a los empleados a ser contagiados con
kobe 19 los gobiernos y también las
agremiaciones estudian algunas maneras
para poder regularlo y dar mejores
garantías a los trabajadores y buscar
una especie de gana gana entre el
empleado y el empleador ya pesar de
tener la cuarentena más larga del mundo
argentina superó el millón de casos de
contagio de kobe 19 es el sexto país a
nivel mundial pero el número de
fallecidos sigue siendo una de las tasas
de mortalidad más bajas de américa más
bajas de américa latina' por millón de
habitantes
les contaremos qué es lo que ha sucedido
en este país y cuáles son los otros
territorios de nuestra región que están
próximos a romper también esa barrera
del millón de casos comenzamos
pues esta semana ya lo decíamos la
universidad de oxford y el del reino
unido- y el laboratorio astrazéneca
anunciaron el fallecimiento de uno de
sus voluntarios que pertenece a uno de
estos estudios que está siendo
adelantado en brásil las autoridades de
ese país suramericano no confirmaron la
información dada a conocer por la
universidad y por la farmacéutica que
lideran este estudio para el desarrollo
de una vacuna contra el kobe 19 tampoco
especificaron cómo murió si recibió la
dosis de la vacuna o si recibió algún
placebo dado que estos datos están
amparados en la confidencialidad que
requieren este tipo de estudios algunos
medios locales especularon sobre la edad
del voluntario también las causas que
podría haber en torno a su fallecimiento
mientras que la universidad de oxford
defendió la seguridad de este ensayo
clínico
y para analizar este tema saludamos a
javier tello él es médico cirujano
analista de políticas de salud pública
doctor tello gracias por estar con
nosotros aquí en france24 y qué tan
normal o qué tan esperado son este tipo
de episodios en los que algunas de las
personas en las que se está tratando
alguna de estas vacunas fallece en estos
procesos de investigación
bueno noches santiago si mira es un
proceso verdaderamente normal te voy a
decir por qué cuando tú estás haciendo
un estudio de fase 3 ya un estudio de
investigación abierta con muchos
voluntarios estamos hablando de
poblaciones que son de 30.000 creo que
en este caso hasta 60.000 voluntarios
como tú comprenderás hay una poca hay
una población muy heterogénea de hombres
y de mujeres de distintos grupos de edad
que según como se hayan puesto y alguno
de ellos va a morir por alguna causa lo
importante es saber cuando se hayan
hecho todos los estudios
correspondientes de que murió este
paciente uno puede ser que murió por
alguna causa atribuible a algo que tenga
que ver con el estudio no hablo de la
vacuna sino con el estudio o pudo haber
muerto de otra cosa por ejemplo el
hombre se infarto la mujer se infarto no
lo sabemos por alguna causa que no tiene
nada que ver una vez que hayamos visto
que es relativo al estudio en solamente
entonces se analiza y se rompen los
protocolos de seguridad porque este es
un estudio doble ciego una persona
normal que está en uno de estos estudios
no sabe si está recibiendo placebos y
está recibiendo vacunas si hubiera
recibido vacuna entonces y solamente
entonces se ve si las causas de la
muerte fueron atribuibles a esta vacuna
sí doctor t yo ya claro que cuando digo
que tan normal es en estos casos no es
que estén normalizando la muerte de una
persona que está como voluntaria en este
tipo de casos sino que es habitual
sucede en este tipo de investigaciones
usted ya nos estaba adelantando algunas
de las posibles causas de los posibles
factores que están en juego y que pueden
salir mal y afectar a estos voluntarios
en el caso específico de este tipo de
vacuna contra un coronavirus una persona
que vive en brasil en un clima tropical
cuáles pueden haber sido los factores
los posibles factores digámoslo así de
una de un fallecimiento estando en este
estudio en desarrollo
mira yo me voy a ir a la epidemiología
general de este estudio está hecho
principalmente en la gente que puede ser
más susceptible de una enfermedad grave
por coronavirus si estamos hablando de
adultos de más de 50 55 años y hay que
reconocer que las personas que tenemos
esa edad pues ya estamos en un factor de
riesgo importante entonces si nosotros
lo valoramos en cuanto al riesgo que
pueden tener la primera causa de muerte
a nivel general brasil o no brasil puede
ser un evento cardiovascular no
descartamos para nada que esta persona
hubiera muerto porque tuvo algún infarto
o alguna cuestión así número 2 que
pudiera haber tenido un evento
trombótico también y que hubiera muerto
por una trombosis lo que habría que ver
solamente para que la gente lo entienda
lo que habría que ver en todo caso es
que esta muerte por algún evento que
puede ser de las primeras causas de
muerte que hay en el mundo eventos
cardiovasculares eventos de trombosis
cerebral etcétera no hubiera sido
desatado por algún componente propio
pero esto para esto hay que probar
primero todo lo que ya platiqué antes
correcto claro queda aclarado este punto
doctor tello como su nombre lo dice los
voluntarios acuden a este tipo de
investigaciones a este tipo de historias
médica desarrollar este tipo de
historias médicas de manera voluntaria
por cuenta propia pero en este caso en
el que el voluntario lamentablemente
fallece qué responsabilidad asumiría
entonces en este caso la farmacéutica y
la universidad de oxford puntualmente
que carga tienen ahí las empresas
desconozco el contrato que se realizó
entre ellos pero normalmente uno como
voluntario firma uno un documento que se
llama disclaimer que es un descargo de
responsabilidades en donde uno dice y
firma que acude conociendo todos los
riesgos que pueden ocurrir si entonces
uno está eximiendo de responsabilidad
porque voluntariamente se está acercando
a ellos ahora bien en algunos casos y
repito desconozco el contrato que está
firmado pero en algunos casos pudiera
ser que se presentaran eventos que no
tenían absolutamente nada que ver o que
no estaban medidos y en ese caso bueno
habría que ver entonces los términos de
la responsabilidad sin ser abogado y
repito sin conocer el contrato lo que te
puedo decir es que todo queda
perfectamente claro y cada una de las
personas que van allá están informadas
de los riesgos que pueden tener en tanto
a los que se conocen los que se pudieran
conocer o los que no se conocen y
pudieran presentarse doctor tanto la
universidad de oxford como el
laboratorio astrazéneca han defendido la
seguridad
ensayo clínico de hecho ya anunciaron
que van a seguir adelante con su
investigación que tan tranquilos podemos
estar nosotros los usuarios del común
los que posiblemente en un futuro vamos
a estar recibiendo esa vacuna después de
una investigación que compruebe que
efectivamente funciona es un excelente
pregunta santiago todas las vacunas
hasta el día de hoy que se conocen
quiero ser bastante claro con ello son
seguras todas porque porque han pasado
por procesos muy largos de investigación
cuando han llegado a presentar algunas
reacciones colaterales claramente las
conoces tú sabes que con algunas vacunas
te va a doler el músculo o vas a
presentar algunos eventos que parecen
fiebre y te lo dicen de antemano no para
que una vacuna pueda salir al mercado
pueda ser autorizada por las autoridades
sanitarias de todos los países en el
mundo tiene que tener un rango de
seguridad muy importante creo que la
gente tiene que y esto es importante
decirlo la gente tiene que sentirse
tranquila para que cuando eventualmente
lleguemos a tener alguna de estas
vacunas confiemos en que nuestras
autoridades sanitarias
y regulatorias han pasado todos los
filtros y hay que decirlo también
estamos hablando de fabricantes de
primer nivel no estamos hablando de
aficionados todas estas empresas conocen
muy bien a nivel ético a nivel
regulatorio a nivel científico todos los
puntos que tienen que tener cubiertos
para mantener una vacuna segura
disponible la población doctor techo
este lamentable hecho que estamos
reportando la muerte de este voluntario
ha un poco esta investigación
ya lo hemos dicho pero hay mucha
expectativa mucha incertidumbre en torno
al desarrollo de las vacunas está
prácticamente esta carrera internacional
por quién es el país cuál es la
farmacéutica que desarrolla la vacuna lo
más pronto posible debemos seguir siendo
cautos con la espera de esta vacuna
porque este tipo de episodios puede que
se sigan presentando
a futuro en el mediano plazo y nuestra
mejor arma entonces va a seguir siendo
el tapabocas el lavado de manos y el
distanciamiento social
absolutamente que es muy bueno mira no
hay que echar por la borda el hecho de
que la mayor parte de las vacunas han
tardado décadas en desarrollarse y estas
vacunas están tomando apenas unos meses
sin embargo como bien dices es muy
probable que algunas cosas no salgan
como queremos y lo más probable es que
la gente tiene que entender que la
vacuna no va a estar disponible hasta
antes de la primavera o del verano del
año que entra la que sea la más avanzada
y después de ello las autoridades
locales de cada uno de sus países
santiago van a tener que hacer una labor
titánica para poder vacunar a miles de
millones de personas esto no se ha hecho
jamás jamás en la historia de la
humanidad entonces tenemos que
mentalizarnos para seguir viviendo
protegidos no salir a la calle no
estarnos reuniendo si no es
indispensable y sobre todo utilizar
cubrebocas tener aislamiento social
mantener el lavado de las manos esto no
se va a terminar el año que entra
santiago la gente tiene que entender qué
la pandemia llegó para quedarse la
vacuna nos va a ayudar la vacuna va a
salvar vidas pero no en varios meses o
en varios años doctor rápidamente para
usted al que es mejor apostarle a una
vacuna al desarrollo de esta o al
desarrollo de un tratamiento que pueda
curar la enfermedad lamentablemente yo
creo que a este punto vamos hacia la
vacuna tenemos que aprender mucho porque
porque es además en donde estamos viendo
algunos resultados quiero ponerlo en
este contexto nosotros hoy vivimos con
una pandemia muy grande desde hace 40
años que es el hb y el sida y si tú te
fijas lo único que hemos logrado para
poder defendernos de la hb y el sida es
uno cambiar nuestras conductas
personalísimas de vida eso es lo primero
número dos hay un tratamiento que ha
logrado hacer que una enfermedad mortal
se convierta en una enfermedad crónica
que puede ser llevadera con medicamentos
pero la vacuna nunca se desarrolló aquí
en contraparte tenemos una vacuna que
está algo adelantada pero
los tratamientos disponibles hay uno que
en medio puede ayudar a algunas personas
muy graves creo que un tratamiento
todavía va a tardar más doctor t yo
muchas gracias por haber estado con
nosotros en france 24 un gusto conversar
con usted y explicarnos este punto
importante muchas gracias y mientras que
en europa varios países están
restableciendo restricciones y medidas
de confinamiento a raíz del aumento de
contagios en américa latina siguen
avanzando las medidas de apertura entre
ellas la apertura de las fronteras para
fomentar la industria turística que es
uno de los sectores más golpeados así
están las cosas veamos
de los 10 países que encabezan la lista
mundial de los más contagiados por
coronavirus 5 son latinoamericanos
-brasil es el que registra más contagios
superando los 5 millones de casos y las
153 mil muertes es el segundo país con
más fallecidos en el mundo después de
eeuu a pesar de las cifras el país
avanza en un proceso de des escalada de
las restricciones desde junio en esta
favela en río de janeiro el comercio en
las calles y la atención en los
restaurantes se imponen ante la nueva
normalidad aunque el número de contagios
por joven 19 sigue aumentando en buenos
aires- se han relajado las estrictas
medidas de restricción con la reapertura
de restaurantes escuelas que ahora
dictan clases al aire libre los vuelos
domésticos y también los centros
comerciales
emocionados los chicos también por qué
cómo funcionaba y
qué pasa con la gente
y como para salir también un poco de
caza me parece bien que habrá mucha
gente que depende de él
así como en argentina en colombia a
pesar de que el país se acerca al millón
de contagiados el gobierno estudia la
posibilidad de reabrir la frontera
terrestre con ecuador- cerrada desde en
marzo por la pandemia y lo que esperamos
esta semana esta semana tanto con el
ministro fernando ruiz evaluando todas
las condiciones es que podamos tener
también una teleconferencia con el
equipo del ecuador y ponernos la tarea
de poder hacer esa reapertura a partir
del primero de noviembre el gobierno del
perú hace un esfuerzo por reactivar el
turismo con campañas publicitarias que
anuncian el regreso gradual de uno de
los sectores más golpeados por la
pandemia y méxico le sigue a perú en la
lista mundial el país descendió en el
ranking global sin embargo siguen
medidas como las restricciones
fronterizas con eeuu para el tránsito
terrestre no esencial y si bien avanza
la reapertura de muchos países de la
región el teletrabajo y el estudio en
casa sigue siendo algunas de las medidas
que permanecen para seguir haciendo
frente a la pandemia
trabajo ha representado todo un reto
para las autoridades las agremiaciones y
para los mismos trabajadores ahora se
planea la posibilidad de regularlo para
generar una especie de gran a ghana de
condiciones entre las empresas y también
obviamente los empleados vamos a conocer
con herlein segura ella es docente e
investigadora integrante de la academia
internacional de transformación del
trabajo y también es promotora e
investigadora del teletrabajo vamos a
conocer más detalles en torno a este
tema hay airlines muchas gracias por
estar con nosotros acompañarnos aquí en
france 24 y a lo largo de estos meses de
confinamiento de los siete meses que
llevamos haciéndole frente a la pandemia
de la incursión del teletrabajo ya ha
dejado algunas reflexiones ya ha dejado
algunas lecciones cuál es el balance que
se puede hacer hasta el momento
bueno el teletrabajo tiene como
divididas las opiniones hay muchas
personas que de acuerdo con su propia
experiencia de las organizaciones
consideran que no quieren seguir que
quieren volver a la sede central las
empresas dicen tengo mis estaciones de
trabajo aquí sin embargo hay encuestas
que dan cuenta de las dos posiciones de
querer volver o de quedarse porque le
han encontrado en sus grandes beneficios
personalmente pienso que los beneficios
son grandes quien tiene posibilidades
que ayuda a la inclusión laboral y que
pues que seguramente si vamos
alejándonos de lo emocional que ha sido
el choque de llegar en adulta mente
hacia práctica pues entonces vamos a
encontrarle todos los beneficios yo creo
que las empresas la mayoría están muy
logrará identificar que si tiene muchos
beneficios sin embargo hay un asunto de
cambio cultural de gestión del cambio
que todavía tiene que incorporarse heart
lane que dice la experiencia en cuanto
al teletrabajo con respecto al desempeño
que normalmente se venía teniendo de los
empleados en las oficinas en el trabajo
antes de que los gobiernos impusieran
las medidas de los confinamientos en los
diferentes países
bueno antes del teletrabajo que se
promovía incluso desde la academia pues
tenía como unas directrices que yo dice
bueno tal vez también nos tendremos que
cuestionar cuando acabe todo este tema
de la pandemia cuál será el teletrabajo
que se va a quedar yo creo que las
empresas han aprendido
para las que ya tenían un piloto de
trabajo incorporado sirviendo no tenían
con todo el personal pues vieron que
podía ser más extensivo a otras áreas de
sus organizaciones
los empleados han aprendido que si es
posible yo creo que ha sido como un
curso intensivo en adoptar esas
prácticas para encontrar sus ventanas
sus desventajas y en que hay que mejorar
car line a estas alturas es necesario
comenzar a pensar en una regulación en
una especie de normativa también de
legalidad de muchas de las actividades
que se hacen dentro del confinamiento o
dentro del teletrabajo
bueno ya varios países se han regulado
el teletrabajo colombia es un país
pionero en regulación del teletrabajo en
la región latinoamericana sin embargo en
eeuu desde los 90 en méxico también algo
se había mencionado
es necesario regularlo pero tratar de
adaptarse muchísimo las circunstancias
porque a veces la regulación puede
también traer algunas dificultades en
que es muy difícil cumplir con todo lo
que se estipula la ley pero yo sí creo
que es importante para darle todas las
garantías laborales y también a la
organización que se haga una regulación
acaba con el confinamiento en colombia
se emitió aparte de la ley que ya
teníamos desde desde el 2008 y el
decreto reglamentario en el 2012 se han
tenido que ir metiendo algunas
resoluciones circulares para ir
trabajando en temas específicos
relacionados con el teletrabajo
en la región ya había países que tenían
ley pero que muchos llegaron a ellas y
aceleraron su proceso con el
confinamiento y con el cobijo usted cree
que estamos ante todo lo que hemos
vivido en los últimos siete meses y las
lecciones que usted ya nos estaba
mencionando que dejar teletrabajo que
estamos ante un evidente punto de
quiebre a nivel laboral a nivel mundial
con todo esto que nos ha sucedido en los
últimos meses
y definitivamente en la academia a veces
cuando comenzó todo este asunto de la
pandemia que al principio era como
difícil
creer que estaba pasando pues yo creo
que ya se dio como un curso intensivo
que nos hizo cuestionar que nos hizo dar
cuenta de que si es posible saber los
que estamos apasionados por el
teletrabajo y lo que venimos promoviendo
lo y investigando lo sabíamos qué era
posible pero yo creo que ya con este
curso intensivo que tuvimos que hacer
frente al teletrabajo en el mundo o sea
porque no fue ni siquiera en una región
específica sino en el mundo yo creo que
ya sea como en un contexto para
identificar qué fue lo bueno lo malo lo
feo del teletrabajo y lograr
incorporarlo e identificar que que es
que podría ser mejor que prácticas y en
qué tiempo tenemos que trabajar para que
sea mejor airlines algunos países
nórdicos como por ejemplo suecia
finlandia noruega y dinamarca ya tenían
desde hace varios años atrás algunas
horas a la semana
para que sus empleados trabajarán en sus
casas para compartir más tiempo en
familia o simplemente por calidad de
vida sobre todo con esos fuertes
inviernos que tienen en esa zona de
europa en américa latina pues para
nosotros ha resultado una novedad esta
masificación del teletrabajo en la
región debido a la pandemia pero aquí en
américa latina todavía estamos luchando
por algunas por algunos derechos básicos
de la dignidad laboral todavía hay
algunos sectores donde prácticamente hay
una esclavitud laboral debido a las
condiciones pero américa latina' ya
quiere saltar al teletrabajo y quiere
que se expanda un poco más teniendo en
cuenta que solamente el 21 por ciento de
la gente en américa latina' puede hacer
el teletrabajo no estamos tratando de
caminar y correr cuando ni siquiera
estábamos gateando bien si me hago
entender con el término
si yo comprendo lo que me comenta
si nosotros en latinoamérica tenemos una
cultura y una circunstancias muy
diversas y yo creo que
si bien tenemos algunas conquistas
laborales ganadas también es claro que
hay algunas que todavía no se han dado y
que probablemente con el teletrabajo
puedan profundizarse yo creo que
latinoamérica por su cultura tiene su
propio adn y su forma de hacer las cosas
en esos países nórdicos perdón en sus
países nórdicos que ustedes menciona el
teletrabajo ni siquiera sabía que
enamoraba no porque es que hacía parte
de su vida las estaciones obligan a
teletrabajar el clima es tan severo que
la gente sabe que hay meses en los que
no puede desplazarse ni mandar los hijos
a estudiar para nosotros que somos como
más del caribe del trópico todo es un
poco más flexible tenemos un clima que
nos ayuda a estar
elaborando la mayor parte del tiempo yo
creo que hay que seguir insistiendo que
hay que seguir insistiendo que ésta ha
sido una oportunidad de oro para
continuar
insistiendo en construir una metodología
de teletrabajo afianzar una modalidad de
teletrabajo revisar la regulación y
tratar de defender las las luchas
laborales un dato importante allí
santiago es que por ejemplo en españa
hace muchos años cuando se empezó a
tratar de incorporar el teletrabajo
los sindicatos se oponían se oponían
porque decían que eso ha influido en que
las personas no pudieran encontrarse en
sitios para pedir sus derechos cierto y
ahora se han dado cuenta que las tics
pueden contribuir incluso a ser más
virales sus peticiones ya lograr que sus
conquistas laborales y las que les
faltan puedan ser un poco más global
y locales entonces yo creo que es un
aprendizaje constante heart lane para
terminar se habla mucho del teletrabajo
a lo largo de esta pandemia pero también
eso aceleró la automatización que es
otro tema importante a nivel laboral
estamos los empleados ante un punto de
quiebre vuelvo a tomar la misma
expresión y tenemos algo de que
preocuparnos teniendo el teletrabajo y
la automatización en una rápida
expansión ya el foro económico mundial
dice que hay en riesgo 85 millones de
puestos de trabajo en los próximos cinco
años debido a la automatización
bueno de eso siempre se ha hablado
cuando se piensa en la inteligencia
artificial que es lo que se está
mencionando pero se habla también de la
posibilidad de otros trabajos porque no
todo podría ser automático siempre va a
haber como una transición como fuerte y
que iba a implicar unos sacrificios
bastante grandes pero que luego muchas
estrellas que va a haber unas grandes
conquistas al respecto harlem muchas
gracias por haber estado con nosotros
aquí en france24 habernos acompañado
aquí en esta emisión de kobe 19 la
semana en américa importantes puntos y
explicaciones los que usted tiene en su
intervención muchas gracias
en otros temas persisten los casos de
estudiantes que por falta de conexión o
cobertura del servicio de internet no
han podido continuar con su educación de
manera virtual
muchos de ellos han comenzado a trabajar
dado que tienen mucho tiempo libre según
unicef cerca de 1500 millones de menores
de edad en todo el mundo se han visto
afectados por el cierre de sus escuelas
y por la falta de conectividad
en las montañas de chiapas el pequeño
andrés golpea con un martillo en la roca
durante horas con la esperanza de
encontrar una pieza de ámbar por la que
le pueden pagar a su padre de 1 a 5
dólares desde marzo empezó a trabajar en
la mina a tiempo completo gana apenas
unas monedas que servirán para comprar
alimentos para su familia la escuela de
andrés lleva cerrada casi todo el año
desde que la pandemia de kobe 19 obligó
a los alumnos a quedarse en casa y si el
papá va a la milpa balka fetal va a la
mina el niño no va a quedar en casa pues
nada más
sin hacer nada miran para ello hacer que
quede mirada televisión si tiene
televisión pues es como que estuviera
perdiendo el tiempo
[Música]
poblaciones de
en otro poblado de chiapas agustina
ayuda a sus hijos a leer textos en una
cama que sirve de escritorio sin embargo
sienten no estar a la altura de lo que
ellos requieren yo dices pongo las
tareas estoy poniendo en una tarea así
para que vayan vayan
recordando pues pero no es igual como un
maestro yo soy un campesino no puedo
enseñar mucho a mis hijos
la cepal indica que méxico es el segundo
país en américa latina después de brasil
en donde más trabajo infantil hay cerca
de 23 millones de menores de edad
trabajan y casi el 90% de ellos lo hacen
en actividades peligrosas para su edad
en estos tiempos de crisis de trabajo en
un until se convierte en un mecanismo de
supervivencia para muchas familias
pero si hay un aumento
en la pobreza muchos más se van a ver
empujarlos hacia asia del trabajo
infantil si bien la ley mexicana prohíbe
que los menores de 14 años trabajen
muchos de ellos deben ayudar a sus
familias con ingresos precarios
y argentina es el país con la cuarentena
más larga del mundo siendo así superó el
millón de casos confirmados de kobe 19
lo que lo convierte en el sexto país en
el mundo con la mayor cantidad de casos
después de eeuu india brasil rusia y
francia en la región de américa latina
colombia con más de 990.000 casos perú y
méxico- se aproximan a romper esa
barrera del millón de casos confirmados
así están las cosas
argentina y hace el quinto país del
mundo en superar el millón de casos de
coronavirus según confirmó el ministerio
de salud este lunes hoy fueron
confirmados 12 mil 982 nuevos casos de
ccoo y 19 con estos registros suman un
millón dos mil 662 positivos en el país
en las últimas 24 horas se notificaron
451 nuevas muertes con un promedio
diario de más de 13 mil casos argentina
se convierte en la nación más pequeña en
alcanzar el millón de casos la explosión
de las infecciones ha puesto a prueba en
los hospitales las camas de unidades de
cuidados intensivos en el país están
ocupadas en más del 64 por ciento en
algunas provincias los sistemas de salud
están a punto de colapsar
y creo que ninguno de los que están en
mi situación y son médicos igual que
somos de terapia intensiva
deben tener mismo pensamiento que yo
estamos todos estresados o sea no se
puede entender si en un principio la
mayoría de los casos se encontraban en
buenos aires- hoy provincias alejadas de
la capital se ven muy impactadas también
es que ahora hay un rebrote de casos que
a todos
nos preocupa el doble y nos preocupa el
doble porque los casos son los contagios
son mucho más cercanos entonces lo que
antes era un caso que no sabíamos quién
era o una cuestión aislada ahora es un
caso que es nuestro vecino que es
nuestro mejor amigo argentina impuso
estrictas medidas el 20 de marzo poco
después de que se confirmara el primer
caso de kobe 19 en el país al inicio el
país estaba entre los buenos alumnos
pero tras siete meses de confinamiento
el gobierno reabrió gradualmente la
economía con las consecuencias que
observamos hoy
ya lo decíamos colombia méxico y perú se
aproximan rápidamente al millón de casos
de contagio esto evidencia que américa
latina sigue siendo el foco de la
pandemia algo decretado por la oms desde
el pasado mes de julio los desafíos que
tiene nuestra región se los presentamos
en el siguiente reportaje
justo cuando se cumplen siete meses de
cuarentena en argentina la nación con el
confinamiento más largo del mundo superó
la barrera del millón de contagios por
coronavirus y hemos visto un aumento
persistente y progresivo de casos en
centro y suramérica y eso genera una
gran preocupación para nosotros función
está la situación que colombia perú y
méxico- todas con más de 850 mil
contagios según la universidad johns
hopkins también llegarían al millón de
enfermos a finales de octubre américa
latina' suma a la fecha más de 8
millones de contagios desde enero y a
pesar de los confinamientos la situación
parece estar cada vez peor levantar de
forma prematura las cuarentenas puede
generar una insurgencia de infecciones y
causar daños a largo plazo en la
economía la sensatez de la población
está a prueba colombia reporta
manifestaciones como la minga indígena
que resulta en aglomeraciones y posibles
contagios
méxico instauró un sistema semáforo para
determinar la condición de sus estados
sin embargo reporta más de 86 mil
muertes por el virus y perú con dos
camas en la unidad de cuidados
intensivos por cada 100.000 habitantes
tiene un sistema de salud que
da abasto la brecha económica y social
hacen que el acceso a insumos de salud
sean casi un lujo para la mayoría de la
población en estos países con un
inminente millón de casos el hambre
también será un efecto de la pandemia
brasil argentina colombia perú méxico y
chile representan el 23.5 por ciento de
los casos de kobe 19 a nivel mundial
y en nuestra sección en redes veamos
otras noticias destacadas de la semana
aquí en kobe 19 la semana en américa la
fd a la administración federal de
alimentos y medicamentos de estados
unidos aprobó el recibir como
tratamiento para el cob y 19 en ese país
norteamericano se trata de uno de los
medicamentos utilizados para tratar al
presidente estadounidense donald trump
cuando éste padeció el coronavirus y su
uso fue autorizado de emergencia
justamente para tratar al mandatario
según el instituto de salud en nacional
los estudios demostraron que con el uso
del recibir la hospitalización se redujo
en cinco días para la mayoría de los
pacientes tratados
fronteras cerradas en el verano y 15
días sin clases en ribera por el avance
de el coronavirus así titulaba el diario
el país de uruguay haciendo alusión al
anuncio hecho por el presidente de ese
país luis lacalle pou quien afirmó que
las fronteras de ese país suramericano
permanecerán cerradas de cara a la
temporada de verano esto en el
hemisferio sur un duro golpe para la
industria turística uruguaya el
mandatario también indicó que dado al
aumento de casos en el país se
extremarán los controles y las medidas
de bioseguridad como sucede en el
departamento de ribera
uruguay tiene fronteras con argentina y
brasil que son dos de los países más
afectados por la pandemia en el mundo
y puerto rico- relaja algunas
restricciones por el kobe 19 esta semana
a wanda vázquez la gobernadora de esta
isla en el caribe anunció que más
personas podrán visitar restaurantes
gimnasios teatros y los casinos en la
isla asimismo serán reactivados los
servicios de transporte público
incluyendo los autobuses los trenes y
los ferrys que podrán ya comenzar a
transportar pasajeros la isla sigue allí
en vigor el toque de queda desde las 10
de la noche hasta las 5 de la mañana en
todo el territorio así como es
obligatorio el uso de la mascarilla
y la agencia france presse anunció que
el ensayo clínico de una posible vacuna
que adelanta a la universidad de oxford
en conjunto con la farmacéutica
astrazéneca contra el kobe 19 ha
reanudado sus investigaciones en eeuu
las partes no han dado mayores detalles
pero la fase de pruebas en humanos o
fase 3 conocida como la fase 3 será
reanudada a la brevedad posible'
y así llegamos al final de kobe 19 la
semana en américa nosotros nos volvemos
a encontrar la próxima semana pueden
dejar sus comentarios a través de las
redes sociales de france24 siga con
nuestra programación feliz fin de semana
para todos
[Música]